this is no barriers and this is that
this is the most challenging thing of
the in my whole career yeah yeah
[Music]
hello I'm Tom Ward and welcome to in my
personal space my guest today has been
called the queen of grime all hail lady
Leisha Alicia hi I'm Tom nice to smell
you it's quite close isn't it very close
[Music]
if I'm gonna be in your personal space
for a while we should have one of these
Nishant yeah sorry about this this
doesn't normally happen to me for anyone
that hasn't heard of you which is very
unlikely could you tell the people what
you do and who you are my name's leave
Alicia I'm from Birmingham or 1t1 um and
I do wet where do you live now if you
live in Birmingham still and I live in
London now unfortunately unfortunately
yeah where'd you live in London um East
London but not sure there's a bit lame
yeah you live in there kind of got
really discourage that kind information
private private this isn't a normal
situation for me it really isn't I've
got a girlfriend now how would she feel
if we was this close she'd be I think
she'd be all right you sure about that
yeah no I think she'd be okay right now
what was the last day's work you did not
that you know you're not working now
funnily enough it was being a security
guard really yes look at me oh you're
not coming in no we we basically just
had to check the toilets and well you
can't get at that looking tough
yeah it's head don't see there can you
remember your first rat I know it was to
a reggae song that my mom used to play
around the house all the time and I just
started you like little voice notes from
my mom's house phone I'll see you
recorded the voice on the voicemail for
the landline here
my mom can't pick up the phone no is
something dialing tone something really
little rut a BCH like that you got used
to fame yet and I guess sir I don't
think I'm famous kind of like you not
famous cheers for that is it possible to
be a rich grime and still have
credibility a rich grime yeah cuz you're
a grime
maya grime yeah yes I think you can
still be rich there's a lot of people in
the grime scene that are very rich some
are millionaires
trying to get to that point you're well
known for rapping without mentioning
violence or drugs or hearing or swearing
but in all of your videos
you're clearly violating the Green Cross
code are you worried that because of you
pavements will become unfashionable no I
think there'll be more in fashion
because I'm walking the streets what
keeps you sane what keeps you sane
remembering that I am Alicia before lady
Alicia yeah yeah no and I always got to
live like I only have ten pound in my
bank ones of you a madly in love with
someone and one night you were in bed
sitting on the bed together and then you
turn round wait for it and that person
had their foot in their mouth and they
were biting off their nails huh that
makes me shudder I would have to block
and delete but you're mad in love but
that is disgusting but what makes you
think I would want to see that do that
in your own time lady Lisa thanks for
letting me in your personal space no
worries I have to do it again yeah come
happen get him I've never wanted to end
[Music]
you